bonjour à tous c'est paléo news
l'émission qui fait les news avec du
violon
alors évidemment la nouvelle qui a
soutenu et internet et toute la paléo
sphère celle annonces fracassantes des
lots de masques qui va bientôt recréer
jurassic park ça y est et le masque
s'attaque enfin la question des
dinosaures après la conquête de mars
il va enfin ressusciter les dinosaures
est évidemment vous avez dû voir passer
cette genre d'annoncé ou ce genre de
d'articles dans la presse et sur les
réseaux sociaux
bientôt un centre d'attraction avec de
vrais dinosaures à la jurassic park
la réponse est non d'ailleurs je
m'adresse ici à tous les journalistes
qui nous regardent
faut arrêter de faire des titres en
forme de question comme ça où la réponse
est évidemment non faut arrêter ça c'est
pas bien alors je sais vous avez faim
peut-être qu'il ya pas grand chose à
dire en ce moment peut-être qu'il ne se
passe rien en tout cas l'actualité
paléontologique n'était pas si pauvre
que ça au moment où cette nouvelle est
sortie
vous allez le voir au cours de cette
vidéo évidemment je ne vais pas parler
que de ça mais voilà vous allez voir
qu'il s'est passé suffisamment de choses
pour qu'on n'ait pas besoin de reporter
ce genre de non nouvelles dunes c'est
non news parce que déjà c'est pas elon
musk qu'a dit ça c'est un de ses potes
je sais plus qui met bref c'est pas lui
et de toute façon quiconque a dit salah
juste balancer comme ça vite fait mal
fait sur twitter
donc c'est pas une c'est pas genre comme
s'il y avait une énorme conférence de
presse pour expliquer à voilà comment on
va ramener les dinosaures à la vie ou
quoi danser c'est un mec à moitié bourg
et sur twitter qui a balancé et on va
refaire des dinosaures on a du pognon on
peut refaire les dinosaures maintenant
on peut pas non on peut passer on va
pour vous dire à quel point niveau
technologique à quel point on peut pas
refaire les dinosaures on va prendre une
allégorie petite métaphore
on en est à peu près aussi près
aujourd'hui de refaire des dinosaures de
faire revivre des dinosaures qu'on en
était d'aller sur mars à l'invention de
la montgolfière
voilà voyez maintenant l'alleud en a
absolument pas la technologie d'ailleurs
si c'était une question de technologie
déjà ce serait vachement bien mais parce
qu'il n'y a pas qu'une question de
technologie il ya juste le registre
fossile c'est à dire que de l'adn de
dinosaures c'est l'année dernière on a
découvert le premier truc qui pouvait
éventuellement commencer à ressembler à
un chromosome de dinosaures et il ya
éventuellement un petit peu de quelques
nucléotides préserver à l'intérieur quoi
il y aurait éventuellement un peu de ça
mais sinon c'est on n'est jamais allé
plus loin que c'est un niveau dit non je
veux dire il ya déjà il ya un problème
de préservation de base et on peut pas
réinventer de l'adn qui n'existe plus ça
quelle que soit la technologie on peut
pas réinventer un adn qui n'existe pas
donc de ça c'est un obstacle quasiment
infranchissable à la re création d'un
dinosaure des dinosaures non aviens
évidemment je précise y en a plein dans
les vidéos dans les commentaires qui
vont m'expliquer mais nier les
dinosaures non aviens puisque les
dinosaures en fait il en existe encore
ça s'appelle les oiseaux il n'y a pas
besoin d recrée oui je sais mais enfin
évidemment quand on parle de ressusciter
les dinosaures on parle pas de
ressusciter un canard qui a vécu vingt
millions d'années on parle bien de
recréer un véritable dinosaures non
aviens qui nous intéresse réellement
comme un tyrannosaure donc voilà on est
on on a déjà un problème de préservation
il faut trouver de l'adn de dinosaures
et ça on en a pas et on en aura
probablement jamais donc 2 voilà et de
toute façon technologiquement parlant ça
passe ça voudrait dire que d'une
non-maîtrise le clonage parfaitement ce
qui n'est pas vraiment le cas non plus
et de deux ça voudrait dire qu'on aurait
qu'on aurait accès à une technologie qui
permet de réparer l'adn
de l'adn qui est impossible à réparer
donc bref c'est juste pour vous dire que
on n'a pas ce qu'il faut pour arriver à
faire revivre les dinosaures et on est à
des centaines d'années de la voir cette
technologie est pour vous dire le jour
où on arrive à ramener un mammouth à la
vie parce que ça à la limite c'est
envisageable
le jeu on arrive à ramener à mammouth à
la vie est notée mémo l'a noté mes mots
le jour on arrive à ramener un mammouth
à la vie on sera à 150 ans au moins du
premier dinosaure recréer au moins à 150
ans donc on est loin de 15 ans on est
loin des 15 ans annoncés dans ce titre
put à cliquer là toute façon tous les
cinq ans il ya un gus qui annonce qu'on
va ressusciter les dinosaures dans cinq
ans et tous les cinq ans ils se trompent
je veux dire tous les cinq ans depuis
les années 80 ça date pas de jurassic
park 1,7 mode c'est tous les cinq ans
depuis les années 80 il ya un gus qui
annonce qu'on va re de faire revivre les
dinosaures et tous les cinq ans le mec
se plante
évidemment il ya les gens les mieux
renseignés qui me diront mais il ya déjà
corner nadja corner qui est un
paléontologue du coup quelqu'un de
sérieux de au moins dans le domaine qui
dit qu'il veut faire revivre des
dinosaures en faisant d évoluer des
poulets donc il dit qu'il va recréer des
dinosaures non aviens en faisant
régresser en fait des poulets au niveau
dinosauriens quoi au niveau non aviens
deux de leurs lignes et donc ça ferait
en fait ça contournerait le problème
qu'il n'y a pas d' à dn préserver de
l'époque où les dinosaures vivaient les
dinosaures non aviens vivait oui mais
non en fait il ya une raison
fondamentale pour laquelle ça n'arrivera
pas et là c'est pareil vous pouvez
écrire ça dans faut prendre des notes
il ya une raison pour laquelle ça
n'arrivera jamais le pouget le projet
chicken zaurus ou poule et aux orres
c'est parce qu'en fait ça n'a jamais été
le but du projet chicano zaurus le
projet chicken zaurus le but n'a jamais
été de créer des dinosaures enfin de
recréer des dinosaures de faire d
évoluer d
des poulets ça le but ça toujours été
chicken zaurus c'est juste la vitrine
pour vendre un projet qui consiste à
étudier l'évolution développementale des
théropodes en utilisant les oiseaux
modernes les gallinacés moderne comme
modèle évolutif
sauf que évidemment si vous essayez de
vendre sa un projet étude de l'évolution
développementale des dinosaures
théropodes en utilisant les gallinacés
comme modèle évolutif
si vous essayez de vendre ça vous y
arriverez jamais personne vous donnera
d'argent ni votre université n'est ni un
ni en privé ni quoi que ce soit personne
ne vous donnera jamais d'argent pour
faire ça par contre si vous dites
chicano russe on va ramener les
dinosaures à la vie en faisant d évoluer
des poulets là vous avez l'attention des
gens et notamment des financeurs donc
voilà le poulet aux orres c'est ça c'est
juste un c'est juste la vitrine d'un
gros projet de d'études des veaux des
veaux les veaux des vols l'évolution
développementale donc laissé juste de
l'evo des veaux à la base le projet n'a
jamais été de faire revivre un dinosaure
jamais et je sais que vous allez me
trouver des conférences de jack corner
où il dit qu'il va le faire
oui c'est le principe d'utiliser ça
comme vitrine c'est de dire qu'on va le
faire mais on le fera jamais ça serait
ça n'a jamais été le but absolument
jamais donc voila et ils ont réussi
effectivement à comprendre mieux le
mécanisme du développement de la queue
et notamment de la disparition de la
queue chez les oiseaux ils ont réussi à
regarder aussi les bras ils me semblent
ils ont publié là dessus ils ont publié
sur la mâchoire aussi comment le bec
devient la mâchoire quels sont les
séquences de gènes qui s'activent se
désactive au cours du développement pour
passer d'un bec d'un d'une bouche de
type alligator à une bouche de type grec
donc voilà ça c'est ça c'était le but du
projet chicano zaurus le but du projet
chez kenzo russe n'a jamais été vont de
recréer des dinosaures en faisant d
évoluer des poulets ceci dit c'est très
amusant comme concept c'est très
éducatif puisqu'on peut l'utiliser pour
expliquer que les dinosaures en fait
enfin que les oiseaux ne songea
et que des dinosaures modifiées
génétiquement modifiées génétiquement
évolué j'ai envie de dire donc voilà
donc non plus le projet poule et aux
orres ou chicken zaurus ça ne mènera à
rien ça ne mènera à rien parce que ça
n'a jamais été le but donc non voilà
arrêtez s'il vous plaît de dire qu'on va
ramener qu'on va faire un jurassic park
bientôt faut arrêter de faire circuler
des nus des news comme ça ça fait mal ça
fait mal parce que ça sert à rien parce
que c'est toujours des faux espoir parce
qu'après les gens donc que ça à la
bouche
après ils ont que des questions
là-dessus c'est des questions qui sont
inintéressantes
en tout cas si ce que je viens de vous
dire là maintenant vous a intéressé bah
tant mieux pour vous mais moi je trouve
ça absolument inintéressant
donc on passe à la suite on passe aux
choses vraiment intéressantes on passe à
la littérature scientifique publiée
voilà ça c'est bon c'est du solide c'est
du hardcore et la première étude qu'on
va utiliser le jour afin qu'on va sur
lesquelles on va s'arrêter aujourd'hui
c'est une étude parue dans pire jay et
qui parle des tyrannosauridés donc d'un
d'un boys band de tyrannosauridés qui
nous date du crétacé alors pourquoi
cette étude est elle intéressante parce
que la vue dit comme ça ça a l'air super
chiant salaire je veux dire c'est une
étude taphonomie qu de a à z c'est la
taphonomie c'est l'étude de comment les
trucs se fossilise et honnêtement même
moi j'ai du mal à lire ça parce que
d'une sèchement c'est très long c'est un
article qui est très long qui fait 50
pages
c'est chiant c'est très technique alors
comment ça se fait que je vous parle de
cet article là il a tout simplement
parce que vous en avez probablement
entendu parler mais sous un autre titre
un titre qui vous annonçait les
tyrannosaures chasse est en meute et oui
alors je vous ai je vous laisse quand
même savourer comment on parle comment
on part de géologie est aphone omis d'un
lit de presse d'un lit préservant la des
tyrannosaures les eaux des tyrannosaures
du campagne à supérieur de cas parole de
la formation qu'à part aux vitz du sud
de l'utah et les applications pour les
la grille car younès comment les
tyrannosaures sont grégaires en gros
voilà comment on est passé de sa as
les tyrannosaures chassent en meute je
vais vous l'expliquer pourquoi pourquoi
comment on est passé de ça déjà il faut
voir que pour publier d'empyr 'j'ai faut
payer très cher ça secoue ça se paye
très cher de publier d'empyr 'j'ai parce
que pierre jesse est un journal qui est
dit open access c'est à dire que c'est
un journal pour lequel il faut payer
très cher pour qu'ils soient gratuits
pour les gens qui le lisent donc c'est
l'auteur s'est pas l'éditeur s'est pas
l'université c'est l'auteur qui payent
pour publier
donc je le dis si le monde de l'édition
fonctionner comme ça il y aurait
beaucoup moins de bouquins je vous
assure
mais bref c'est l'auteur qui payent pour
publier son article ce qui arrive assez
souvent dans la dans la littérature
scientifique dans le grand monde de la
littérature scientifique mais alors pour
psg à purger on paye une quantité
d'argent à ces housses pour ça pas aussi
où ce que pour sayan sénateurs qui sont
les deux autres gros journaux
scientifiques les plus connus mais
pierre g on paye une quantité d'argent
assez ouf par rapport à la popularité en
fait du journal puisque c'est ça en fait
ce qu'on achète quand on paye quand on
paye la publication des journaux ce que
ce qu'achètent les scientifiques en fait
c'est pas c'est la popularité du journal
donc en fait quand on publie dans sa
jeunesse et nature's c'est des journaux
qui sont très très populaire dans la
communauté scientifique donc en fait ce
qu'on paye ses on paye leurs leur
audimat quoi on paye on paye le fait que
beaucoup de gens vont lire notre article
pire jay c'est pas un journal si
populaire que ça et pourtant on paie
extrêmement cher parce que justement on
paye aussi les frais de publication
c'est à dire que le journal article va
être ouvert à tous
donc ça un certain attrait parce qu'on
aime bien quand notre recherche est
ouverte à tous mais du coup ça se paye
très cher
voilà donc il faut payer très cher pour
publier d'empyr jay alors qu'est-ce
qu'on fait du coup pour justifier
d'avoir payé aussi cher bas ont fait un
communiqué de presse parce qu'on veut
dire à 7 chez pas si on est financé par
une compagnie pétrolière par exemple on
va expliquer à cette compagnie
pétrolière que son argent est bien
dépensé et qu'on n'a pas payé c'est un
truc c'est quelque chose comme 2000 ou
3000 euros pour publier dans pire j'ai
donc on n'a pas dépensé 3 1000 boul pour
eux rien on veut leur dire que ça a
servi à quelque chose et pour ça on va
faire un petit communiqué de presse à
air regarder ce qu'on a on a utilisé
votre argent pour publier quelque chose
qui a fait un communiqué de presse et ça
a bien marché et les gens vont aimer et
tout ça tout ça voilà et si c'est votre
université donc c'est de l'argent public
qui est utilisée alors là c'est encore
pire la faut vraiment très très fort
justifié très très fort de vous comment
on utilise l'argent
donc voilà donc on fait un communiqué de
presse
et quand on a et puis on vend ce qu'on
peut vendre et à savoir la ce qu'ils ont
voulu vendre c'était que c'était la
partie
tirano ohrid gregorio snes du titre de
leur bout de leurs de leurs articles
voilà donc est-ce que cet article
démontre que les tyrannosaures chasser
en meute et bien voyons ce qu'ils ont
trouvé donc voilà ce qu'ils ont trouvé
ils ont trouvé un site paléontologique
sur lequel était préservé différents
ossements indiqué par des couleurs ici
donc vous voyez alors il ya pas que des
ossements d'ailleurs il ya aussi du bois
et des charbons déjà en marron et en
noir mais il ya aussi des tortues un
crocodile du genre des noces us
un dinosaure à drouot reid est donc un
herbivore à bec de canard et 2
je crois qu'il y a deux squelettes de
terrato faune et us ou peut-être plus je
suis pas sûr je me rappelle plus
exactement mais bref et de deux
squelettes de terrato faune et us dont
vous voyez au moins un crâne ici
et donc vu qu'il y a plus que 1 tera tôt
funny l'usp réservé à cet endroit
eh bien on fait une grosse digression
sur enfin ils discutent rapidement à la
fin de l'article
la possibilité que ces deux terrato faux
nez soit possiblement morts ensemble et
donc et possiblement vécu ensemble et la
presse en a fait des gros titres du
genre
les tyrannosaures chasser en meute on a
enfin la preuve
non vous avez ici plus qu un spécimen de
terra tofo nice alors déjà avait en plus
si vous aviez imaginé à un seul moment
qu'on allait parler de tyrannosaurus rex
bon bah déjà vous pouvez me votre espoir
est mort et enterré j'ai envie de dire
parce que tu iras ne l'a le
tyrannosauridés en question c'est
terrato phone est donc déjà on a un
petit jeu de mot
petite subtilité la toute petite
subtilité c'est qu'en fait quand on dit
tyrannosaure c'est un terme générique
qui peut recouvrir à la fois
tyrannosaurus rex ou bien la famille des
tyrannosauridés donc qui inclut terrato
fonus ou bien même la famille la super
famille des tyrannosaures aux ide qui
inclut aussi des trucs genre guen longue
quinon qui ne ressemble mais alors
absolument pas un t-rex donc déjà il ya
un petit jeu tu vois ce que tu sens que
tu te fait arnaquer déjà sur le titre
quand on dit les tyrannosaures est les
tyrannosaures chassé en maintenant des
tyrannosauridés chasser en meute et
d'ailleurs terrato faune et c'est
suffisamment éloignée de tyrannosaurus
pour qu'en fait tyrannosaurus et plus
chassée de façon solitaire et erato
fonij de façon en meute 1 je veux dire
comme chez les chats par exemple un chez
les chats vous avez les lions qui
chassent en meute et vous avez les
tigres juste à côté qui chassent en
solitaire donc bref faire attention aux
généralisations abusives déjà mais bref
donc là ce qu'on nous dit c'est qu'en
gros on a retrouvé les squelettes de
terrato fonus ensemble donc ils sont
morts ensemble dont qu'ils ont vécu
ensemble
oui mais non j'ai fait une vidéo de
presque une heure qui parle
exclusivement de ce problème là le
problème de la chasse en meute chez les
théropodes et des grandes histoires de
chasse en meute quand vous
inventer notamment celle de détonique us
l'intelligence des démonistes us et leur
chasse en groupe et commence cette
mythologie est apparue de où elle est
apparue et de pourquoi ces deux là
mythologie
voilà pourquoi c'est faux donc j'ai fait
toute une vidéo là dessus vous n'avez
qu'à la prendre remplacer le mode et
monique us par le moderato fonus et vous
comprendrez pourquoi pourquoi il faut
prendre ça avec des pincettes parce que
retrouver de macchabées ensemble ça
prouve juste que les deux macchabées son
ensemble voilà ça veut même pas
forcément dire qu'ils sont morts
ensemble
c'est vous dire c'est j'aimerais bien
vous dire que vous trouvez de macchabées
ensemble ça veut dire qu'ils sont morts
ensemble mais c'est même pas le cas
c'est même pas le cas vous pouvez avoir
un macchabée un truc qui est mort en
aval de la rivière à deux kilomètres
un truc qui est mort pardon un truc qui
est mort en amont de la rivière à 2km
vous pouvez avoir un truc qui est mort
en amont de la rivière à un kilomètre et
probablement trois semaines plus tard
1 donc voilà maintenant vous avez deux
maccabée qui sont morts à trois semaines
d'intervalle
et là vous avez une crue de la rivière
qui emporte les deux macchabées en bas
en amont et là les deux se retrouvent
fossilisés au même endroit en amont de
la rivière lé vous arrivez en tant que
paléontologues vous dites oh regardez
les tyrannosaures chassé en août
ben non ça veut pas forcément dire
qu'ils chasser en meute
ça veut même pas forcément dire qu'ils
sont morts ensemble est alors de là à
dire qu'ils ont vécu ensemble et qu'ils
étaient en meute
voilà donc ils développent des arguments
quand même pour dire qu'il était plus ou
moins synchrone et enfin qu'ils sont
morts de façon synchrone et tout ça tout
ça mais je veux dire retrouver deux
cadavres ensemble ne sera jamais la
preuve que
que ces deux individus vivaient ensemble
jamais de la vie jamais le seul moyen
c'est de trouver des empreintes de pas
on a des empreintes de pattes
tyrannosauridés qui sont parallèles donc
ça veut dire qu'il ya un tyrannosaure au
moins qui est passé donc un tyrannosaure
au sens famille tyrannosauridés qui est
passé dans un sens et un autre
tyrannosaure qui allaient dans le même
sens à ne même pas forcément dire qu'ils
marchaient ensemble
donc c'est pareil pour dire qu'il
chasser en meute c'est léger c'est très
allégée donc voilà faux-pas faut pas
aller trop loin en besogne avec ce genre
de déclaration voilà dès qu'on vous
montre de toute façon dès qu'on vous dit
l espèce chasser en meute le premier
truc qu'il faut vérifier c'est pourquoi
on dit ça vous vérifiez vous regardez on
a retrouvé une plus à ce que l'être
ensemble c'est mort c'est si on a réussi
on vous dit que les machins chasser en
meute parce qu'on a retrouvé plusieurs
squelettes ensemble mais c'est qu'on
peut rien conclure on a le droit
on a le droit de faire l'hypothèse que
peut-être ils vivaient ensemble et que
c'est pour ça qu'ils sont dans
l'ensemble mais c'est qu'une des
hypothèses parmi les millions
d'hypothèses qui existent de commander
des cadavres peuvent se retrouver
ensemble
voilà donc on a le droit de faire
l'hypothèse mais bon les fed annonce par
contre du coup ils tombent à plat ça
c'est clair on reste dans les t-rex
enfin dans les tyrannosauridés avec
maintenant t-rex justement alors vous
avez vu passer vous avez forcément vu
passer si vous vous intéressez à la
paléontologie une annonce disant que ça
y est on sait enfin combien il y avait
de tyrannosaure il ya eu deux milliards
et demi de tyrannosaure vous avez
forcément vu ce titre quelque part il a
existé deux milliards et demi de
tyrannosaure ça y est on le sait et bien
c est assez paresseux
cette information via de cet article
alors qui a été publiée dans la revue
sayan ce donc sayan ce qui est une des
deux grosses revue les plus populaires
justement de sciences les revues
scientifiques donc c'est les revues qui
sont populaires au sein du monde
scientifique
ça veut pas dire que les gens les gens
temps normal lisent
sayan sénateurs mais bref donc on a le
nombre de tyrannosaure qui a existé
environ deux milliards et demi
d'individus alors comment est-ce qu'on
est arrivé à calculer ça assez simple en
fait les gens là les auteurs de cet
article ont utilisé une des équations
qui existe déjà pour estimer en fait la
quantité d'individus d'espèces moderne
par exemple quand on vous dit que quand
on vous dit qu'il existe je sais pas
reste plus que dix mille éléphants jeudi
au pif j'en sais rien mais quand on vous
dit qu'il reste plus que dix mille
individus d'éléphant on les a pas
comptés
personne ne les a comptés je sais bien
que dans l'absolu il faudrait mais
personne n'a pris le temps de les
compter c'est déjà parce que c'est un
travail extrêmement longues fastidieux
et très cher d'arriver à parcourir
l'afrique entière pour compter combien
il reste des éléphants mais c'est
surtout que les éléphants sa migrent
donc le temps que vous allez mettre à
compter les éléphants d'un côté est ce
que ça veut pas dire que les éléphants
de l'autre côté se seront déplacés vous
allez les comptés deux fois donc
donc voilà on s'emmerde pas à compter
les individus un parent donc ce qu'on
fait c'est qu'on va faire un comptage
dans une certaine zone géographique
on va estimer le nombre d'individus au
kilomètre de ce comptage on va estimer
le nombre d'individus au kilomètre carré
et ensuite on va extrapolé sur la
quantité de kilomètres carrés que
l'espèce entière des éléphants occupe et
là on aura un comptage du nombre
d'éléphants
alors évidemment avec les éléphants ça
marche c'est pas c'est pas forcément le
meilleur exemple parce que la densité de
population varie énormément au sein des
éléphants
vous avez des endroits qui sont
surpeuplés comme la zambie et le
botswana je crois et vous avez des
endroits qui sont sous peuplés comme
certains endroits je crois que ça l'est
tout dit mme bâ bouées ou en afrique du
sud mais bref vous avez vous avez des
inégalités de répartition chez les
éléphants donc c'est pas faux mais c'est
pareil on peut en tenir compte aussi je
veux dire de ces inégalités de
répartition mais le fait est qu'on ne
compte pas les éléphants n'utilise des
équations des équations qui implique de
connaître donc la densité de population
alors comment on estime la densité de
population des tyrannosaures à votre
avis
parce que pour arriver à compter combien
il a existé de tyrannosaure faut arriver
déjà d'une part a estimé combien il ya
eu de tyrannosaure à un instant t de
t-rex à un instant t
donc il faut connaître la densité de
population et leur aire de répartition
géographique donc déjà ça ça va être
compliqué mais en plus pour estimer
combien il y a existé de tyrannosaurus
rex en tout il va falloir aussi tenir
compte du fait que les tyrannosaurus rex
ils ont existé pendant une grande
période de temps une épaisseur
stratigraphique c'est pareil il faut du
coup faut aussi estimé cette épaisseur
stratigraphique donc voilà comment ils
ont fait voilà le tableau donc ils ont
estimé une densité de population une
densité de population qui est estimée au
pif vous annonce donc cette densité de
population estimée au pif
elle va de 1,8 individus ok alors
j'imagine que c'est au kilomètre carré à
4,8 individus ouais c'est bien ça voilà
4,10 individus donc une densité de
population qui varient du simple au
double 1
on a une alors il leur faut aussi le
poids du corps parce que j'imagine que
le poids du corps ça va ça va ça va
aussi influer sur le nombre d'individus
la répartition etc
donc il leur faut le poids du corps donc
pareil une estimation de 3 mx 2 307
jusqu'à presque 7 tonnes donc pareil on
varie quasiment du simple au double et
une estimation de leur distribution en
kilomètres carrés donc là on a un
million quatre kilomètres carrés et
l'eire 3 millions de kilomètres carrés
donc c'est pareil on varie du simple au
double et là le temps pendant lequel les
tyrannosaures ont vécu donc à savoir
pendant 1,3 million d'années estimation
basse voire jusqu'à 3,5 millions
d'années estimations hausse donc là on
varie du simple au triple regardez ça
c'est les paramètres qu'ils font entrer
ses les inputs variable c'est les
paramètres qu'ils font entrer dans leur
équation des paramètres qui donc ont une
variabilité qui va du simple au double
voire du simple au triple à votre avis
ce chiffre de 2,5 milliards d'individus
il a quoi comme marge d'erreur bah ouais
une marge d'erreur colossal une marge
d'erreur que le sale qui rend quasiment
tous leurs résultats inutilisable ça
rend quasiment tous leurs résultats
inutilisable donc voilà les outputs donc
les résultats
voilà donc la densité de population
individus au mètre carré au kilomètre
carré
donc alors du coup ça s'était passé il
avait déjà une densité de population
donc il reste hymne à posteriori la
densité de population c'est intéressant
mais bref vous voyez un chiffre qui
varie donc de 0,1 2,3 0,58 et la de 1,0
point 14 c'est à dire que là vous avez
un chiffre de densité de population qui
varie de quatre ordres de grandeur vous
avez une taille de population qui va de
1300 à 3 128 milles donc séparé une
population qui est une taille de
population qui varie de un ou deux
ordres de grandeurs deux ordres de
grandeur le temps de génération qui
varient de 17 alors c'est peut-être le
seul truc qui est pas trop dégueulasse
voilà de 17 à 20 ans le temps de
génération ça va le nombre de
générations de 66000 à 188 mille donc
c'est pareil deux ordres de grandeur qui
varient du simple au double du simple au
triple même trois fois 6 10 8
du simple au triple le nombre total de
t-rex ce fameux deux milliards et demi
alors ce fameux deux milliards et demi
il est compris entre 1,4 10 puissance 8
et 4,2 10 puissance 10 donc c'est pareil
vous avez une variation de deux ordres
de grandeur entre les deux et là vous
avez encore trois ordres de grandeur
pour la taille pour la préservation donc
le preservation c'est à dire combien de
t-rex se sont en vérité fossilisés et le
nombre d'individus retrouvé par fossiles
du coût qui varie entre quelques
millions à quelques milliards mois là
voilà les voilà le degré de précision je
sais pas comment ça finit publiée dans
science
je sais pas je vois pas comment ces
résultats sont inutilisables
c'est inutilisable je veux dire
écologiquement parlant on peut rien
déduire de ça on peut rien en déduire
pour la biologie de tyrannosaure n'y a
rien qu'on puisse faire avec ces
résultats je vous y rendez pas compte
des variations de plusieurs ordres de
grandeurs quoi densité de population qui
varie de trois ordres de grandeurs sait
rien faire avec ça peut rien faire du
tout alors si les seuls chiffres qui
sont intéressants c'est voilà le nombre
d'individus par fossile donc sachant
qu'on a qu'une centaine d'individus de
tyrannosaure on a une vague idée de
combien on en a raté et donc a priori et
donc a priori ça va 2 1 pour 5 millions
en fin de 1 pour 4 millions et demi à 1
pour 1 milliard
donc en gros si un jour on vous demande
éventuellement si on a déjà découvert
tous les dinosaures
si on n'aurait pas déjà tout déterrer le
dire vous pourrez répondre non ça va on
a de la marge
a priori on a déterré qu'une centaine de
tyrannosaure alors qu'il en a existé des
milliards c'est marrant c'est marrant
parce qu'il ya de marrant aussi c'est
que c'est pas exactement le même chiffre
qui donne là donc c'est un pur 80
millions en train pour 80 millions et 1
pour seize mille dans les zones où les
fossiles sont les plus abondants donc un
pour dix mille ou un pour cent mille
c'est généralement le chiffre qui était
donné par le par les gens qui faisait
les esprits des estimations au pifomètre
comment un fossile pour dix mille
individus ou un peu un fossile pour cent
mille individus qui avaient existé c'est
est ce qu'on pensait donc ouais
maintenant on est on pourrait dire que
en fait c'était peut-être largement
sous-estimées parce qu apparemment ça
peut aller jusqu'à 1 pour plusieurs
millions en tout cas si on en croit le
registre fossile du t-rex qui est pas si
un complet que ça au final
donc c'est à peu près la seule donnée
intéressante que je peut extraire de ce
truc c'est que c'est qu'on a peut-être
largement sous-estimé ce qu'on
connaissait du registre fossile des
tyrannosauridés peut-être qu'on en a
raté beaucoup plus que ce qu'on croyait
ce qui nous ramène d'ailleurs à cet
article là hein faut faire attention à
ce qu'on interprète du registre fossile
parce qu'on n'a pas idée de la quantité
de notre ignorance
en fait et ça c'est une grosse piqûre de
rappel sur on n'a aucune idée en fait de
notre ignorance on n'arrive même pas à
quantifier notre ignorance ans n'arrive
pas à la quantifier précisément quoi
cette ignorance au moins on peut se
permettre de la quantifier ce qui veut
dire que c'est pas non plus voilà on a
dépassé le stade où on faisait du
pifomètre voilà et on regarde dans quel
sens le vent souffle mais même si on a
dépassé le stade du pifomètre ça reste
quand même difficile d'évaluer notre
ignorance on quitte les dinosaures mais
on reste dans les archosaures avec un
nouveau ptérosaures un terreau sort de
la ferme de la famille des darwin
aubeterre ça ne s'invente pas un dîner
un ptérosaure de la famille des darwin
aubeterre du jurassique de chine et qui
a cette particularité bas d'une de très
très très bien préservés comme vous
pouvez voir c'est un beau squelette
complet sur une plaque qui a cette
particularité d'avoir un petit pouce
opposable que vous voyez ici en gros
plan sur une image en 3d très joliment
constitué voilà un ptérosaure qui avait
le pouce opposable et alors vous allez
me dire mais ça veut dire qu'il était
intelligent s'il avait un pouce
opposable
non non non parce que les pouces
opposables n'a jamais été une adaptation
à l'intelligence le pouce opposable est
une adaptation à un mode de vie
arboricole et c'est exactement ce que
vous voyez là le pouce opposable c'est
une adaptation pour grimper aux arbres
et rien d'autre alors les primates ont
tous des pouces opposables et donc les
êtres humains en tant que prime at on
aussi un pouce opposable pouce opposable
qui était de base là pour pouvoir
s'accrocher aux branches et que les
êtres humains ont réutilisé on va dire
au moins pour leurs mains afin de
enfin qu'il réutilise pour fabriquer des
outils afin de fabriquer des outils je
sais pas comment ne pas être finalisée
dans cette phrase mais bref c'est juste
une réutilisation d'un truc qui existait
déjà un des pouces opposables et pouce
opposable et y existait bien avant
l'intelligence humaine est donc
maintenant vous avez un même apte et
rose or les ptérosaures c'est pas les
champions de la taille de cerveau voilà
le pouce opposable c'est un truc de des
espèces arboricoles les iguanes ont des
pouces opposables alors ils ont pas que
les pousses qui sont opposables ils ont
oscillé les index donc à les iguanes ils
ont des doigts opposable les koalas ont
des droits opposables les corps et là
c'est les champions des mammifères pour
ce qui est de la petite taille du
cerveau ils ont un cerveau
ridiculeusement petit les koalas mais
derrière niveau intelligence c'est pas
plus brillant non plus les koalas ça
fait que manger et dormir donc pour
ainsi dire c'est pas exactement des
flèches
les koalas donc bref voilà fawcett ce
petit article je trouve nous rappelle
très bien à quel point le pouce
opposable n'a rien à voir avec
l'intelligence faut arrêter de
maintenant d'associer plus opposable et
intelligence ça ne marchait pas on reste
dans le domaine de l'intelligence
maintenant on va parler du cerveau
directement donc on sort complètement du
domaine des arcs aux orres on passe du
côté des mammifères de la force
et surtout on va s'intéresser aux
homininés j'ai envie de dire le deuxième
sujet le plus bankable
après les dinosaures donc les homininés
on a pas mal d'études qui ont été
publiées récemment sur les hominidés qui
sont très intéressante tout dans des
grandes revues genre sayan ce comme
celle là où nature's pour la suivante
voilà qu'on verra juste après et donc et
ses études il y en a 2 donc les deux que
je vais vous montrer s'intéressent à
l'évolution du cerveau alors là cette
première étude s'intéresse à l'évolution
du lobe frontal est en fait ce qu'ils
ont trouvé
qui est donc ils ont passé au scanner
des des moulages dando crâne et a donc
c'est à dire le moulage de la boîte
crânienne de plusieurs fossiles
d'homininés afin d'en étudier la
morphologie du lobe frontal et voilà ce
qu'ils ont trouvé alors j'ai pris une
image une image beaucoup plus simplifié
par rapport à ce qu'ils mettent dedans
article histoire de pouvoir en parler
parce que sinon c'est très compliqué
mais en gros ce qu'ils ont trouvé
c'est que vous avez une organisation
primitive du lobe frontal qui est
commune aux australopithèques au
chimpanzé et aux premiers représentants
du genre homo donc les homo habilis par
exemple cette organisation vous voyez
c'est vous avez l'air de broca qui est
en jaune ici qui est très importante en
tout du moins qu'on pense qu'elle est
très importante parce que on pense que
c'est par là que se trouve le notre sens
de la grammaire on va dire et quand je
dis la grammaire c'est non seulement la
grammaire du langage donc c'est
important pour l'évolution du langage
mais c'est aussi la grammaire de la
fabrication d'outils le mode d'emploi de
la fabrication d'outils donc là donc la
grammaire du langage et de la série de
mouvements qui permet de fabriquer les
outils trouverait plus ou mois sa source
ou du moins seraient plus ou moins
produite par l'air de broca avec des
grosses guillemets mais bref c'est
important en gros et donc elles seraient
primitif chez les australopithèques chez
homo habilis mais après donc elle
changerait chez les représentants du
genre homo d'asie donc notamment homo
erectus et chez les représentantes plus
tardive du genre homo en afrique
ombrières gaster par exemple donc ce
qu'on y voit c'est qu'en fait l'art de
broca au lieu de se retrouver entre deux
sillons comme elle est là va se
retrouver en fait en cheval sur un
sillon en forme de y
mais ça c'est la conformation qu'on
retrouve chez l'humain moderne
apparemment et donc ça ça aurait des
implications
comme ils le disent sur sur l'évolution
du langage et l'évolution de la de la
façon dont on fabrique les outils mais
ça surtout des implications sur la
phylogénie des homininés notamment parce
qu'ils ont regardé en fait deux
représentants du genre homo qui ont un
petit cerveau à savoir homo floresiensis
et homo naledi donc homo floresiensis
qui vient des îles indonésiennes et qui
est une forme naine d'homo erectus en
tout cas pour autant qu'on sache
mais il ya un débat en fait pour savoir
si du fait qu'il a un petit cerveau vous
voyez qu'ils ont des vous voyez qu'ils
ont des petits cerveaux de l'ordre de 4
en 500 centimètres cubes donc en fait il
ya un débat à savoir est ce que ce petit
cerveau il a été directement hérités
d'ancêtres australopithèques signer ou
bien est-ce que c'est comme on le pense
des homo erectus qui ont ensuite évolué
vers un petit cerveau donc des homo
erectus qui avait un cerveau de l'ordre
de 800 à 1000 cm cube qui ensuite sont
revenus à un cerveau plus petit et
pareil pour mona lady au monal est dit
aujourd'hui on sait pas trop si c'est un
site pareil si les descendants si c'est
un descendant nom d'un genre du vin
représentants du genre homo qui avait un
gros cerveau qui a ensuite évolué vers
une petite taille et un plus petit
cerveau ou bien si c'est ainsi c'est un
résidu on va dire un fossile vivant
voilà d'une époque ou homo avait un
petit cerveau comme à l'époque de moabi
lis quoi donc
donc il ya des débats autour de la
position phylogénétique d'homo
floresiensis et de mona lady en fait
savoir si leur cerveau était un gros
cerveau qui a rétréci ou a toujours été
un petit cerveau est très important pour
déterminer leur position phylogénétique
et il se trouve que homo floresiensis et
au monal et dix comme c'est écrit ici
ont une morphologie qui est plutôt
cohérente avec celle des homo erectus et
l'homo ergaster donc avec ce fameux y au
niveau 2 du lobe frontal au niveau de
l'ère de broca et donc ça ça suggère
très très fortement ben qu'ils avaient
un cerveau pleinement développée que
leurs ancêtres avait un cerveau
pleinement développée et qui est ensuite
redevenue petit et ça c'est très
intéressant du cou ou alors que qu'ils
ont ou alors que le cette fourche en
forme de y
c'est développé avant que le cerveau ne
devienne gros mais en tout cas quoi
qu'il arrive au monal eddy est homo
floresiensis non pas un cerveau aussi
primitif que leur petite taille de
cerveau ne le suggère et ça je trouve
que c'est très intéressant comme
résultat et ça va de pair avec cette
étude qui cette fois s'est intéressé à
l'évolution de la taille du cerveau qui
est qui spoiler alert en fait démontre
que la réduction de la taille du cerveau
ça existe chez le genre homo ça existe
le le cerveau ne fait pas que augmenté
de taille dans le genre homo le cerveau
aussi peut se voir réduire ce peut
rétrécir même chez le genre homo
donc il faut faire attention à ces
tendances évolutif qui consiste à tout
de suite dire si c'est si le cerveau est
plus grosse et forcément plus évolué non
il ya des fois où avoir un petit cerveau
c'est plus avantageux comme par exemple
homo floresiensis dans les îles voilà
qui a subi une évolution insulaire le
rétrécissement de la taille du corps et
du cerveau qui va avec c'est un avantage
ça a été un avantage donc c'est plus
évolués d'avoir un petit cerveau dans ce
cas là c'est dire qu'un plus petit
cerveau c'est plus évoluer sa ac ça
calme
il ya des contextes dans lesquels avoir
un plus petit cerveau c'est mieux c'est
plus évolués et donc cette étude là elle
le démontre
alors ce qu'ils ont fait c'est ce qui
est ce que je trouve très intéressant
c'est qu'au lieu de faire la proche
classique pour étudier l'évolution du
cerveau qui consiste à mettre la taille
du cerveau comme ça et le temps comme ça
et puis tracer une jolie droite là qui
montre que le cerveau augmente augmente
augmente augmente
est ce qui oblige du coup à négliger les
représentants du genre homo à petit
cerveau que son mot naledi homo
floresiensis parce que évidemment ils ne
tiennent pas sur la droite
eux ils ont un petit cerveau c'est des
espèces qui ont vécu récemment
relativement récemment mais qui ont un
petit cerveau donc ils tiennent pas là
sur ta droite d'augmentation graduelle
de la taille du cerveau en fonction du
temps alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait pas on
les ignore
bah oui mais c'est pas comme ça qu'il
faut faire faut pas ignorer les outsider
alors pour pouvoir tenir compte des
outsideurs eh bien ils ont fait une
approche phylogénétique de l'étude de la
taille du cerveau
et puis parce qu'ils trouvent c'est très
intéressant c'est que l'encéphale
isation donc la taille du cerveau par
rapport au corps augmente
voilà donc là on a je vous montrais up
donc plus l'encéphale isation et petits
dons plus la taille du cerveau par
rapport au camp un petit plus et foncez
et plus c'est clair plus ça veut dire
qu'on a un gros cerveau par rapport à la
taille du corps l'a regardé au monal et
10 commence clair fini foncé et pareil
pour homo floresiensis donc si on le met
groupe frère de deux homos erectus
asiatiques
ça commence avec un gros cerveau et la
taille du cerveau se réduit voilà et
puis après ils ont ils ont testé
plusieurs scénarios évolutifs où la
tendance est plus ou moins marqué voilà
ils ont mis par exemple en testant au
monal ai dit aux côtés de homo erectus
africains donc ce qu'on appelle un casse
tête
c'est pareil on commence avec un gros
cerveau qui serait tracy là ils ont mis
homo floresiensis donc là ils ont
considéré le scénario ou homo
floresiensis serait directement issues
des australopithèques donc là là par
contre on constate que ça commence un
petit peu enfin c'est à peu près la même
couleur quoi donc on aurait relativement
stable donc en testant plusieurs
scénarios évolutifs en fait on se rend
compte que les scénarios évolutifs qui
sont les plus acceptées comme par
exemple celle que celui que homo
floresiensis et des arrivées d'homo
erectus et bas ce sont ceux où
l'évolution ou le cerveau doit se
rétrécir en fait et donc ça c'est hyper
intéressant donc ça veut dire que la
réduction du cerveau c'est quelque chose
c'est un phénomène existant dans
l'évolution humaine et qu'il faut en
tenir compte
il faut en tenir compte voilà et ça va
complètement de père justement avec cet
article là qui dit qu'elle a un qui
suggèrent qu'en fait les homo naledi
homo floresiensis avait un cerveau
évolue et qui était à la fois gros et
avec cette forme en y sur l'air de broca
et qu'ensuite leur cerveau s'est rétréci
mais ils ont conservé quand même ce
sillon en forme de y
donc là ces deux articles
complètement l'inde en main dans la main
pour nous indiquer que l'évolution du
cerveau elle est beaucoup plus
compliquée qu'on ne l'imaginait c'est
pas juste une histoire d'augmentation de
taille en fait on reste dans le genre
homo avec cette nouvelle étude
alors nouvelle étude d'ailleurs qui est
colorée par une chercheuse française
sandrine prat d'ailleurs comme l'étude
sur le cerveau vous voyez que la ornella
bertrand c'est aussi une chercheuse
française donc les chercheuse française
à l'honneur dans ce palais aux news donc
miguel caparros et sa collègue sandrine
prat ont publié ce nouvel article qui
qui est en fait une étude de la
définition du genre homo mais du point
de vue phylogénétique et ça c'est une
grande nouvelle
vouloir étudier la définition du genre
homo du point de vue phylogénétique
parce que en fait depuis plusieurs
depuis depuis les années 70 la
définition qu'on s'accordent à avoir du
genre homo c'est l'être humain
enfin l'eau minée qui fabrique les
outils sauf qu'il ya un énorme problème
avec cette définition du genre homo
c'est que pour ça faut trouver des
outils en même temps que vos faux cils
quoi si vous voulez déterminer si vous
fossiles appartiennent au genre homo va
falloir trouver des outils avec et c'est
pas toujours le cas
vous n'avez pas toujours le registre
archéologiques ne se superposent pas au
registre paléontologique
systématiquement dans l'absolu ce qu'il
faudrait même trouvé c'est en fait votre
squelette avec un outil dans la main est
mort en train de faire ça voilà il ya un
éclat qui lui est reparti dans l'oeil il
est mort sur le coup et fossilisés et là
éventuellement celui là vous pourriez
dire c'est un représentant du genre oh
no voilà historiquement on a toujours
associé au mot à la fabrication d'outils
c'est bien pour ça qu'on parle d' homo
habilis pour le tout premier
représentant du genre oh no sauf que le
problème c'est que l'applicabilité de
cette définition à les proches du néant
et elle est tellement proche du néant
quand fait maintenant on a même un
énorme problème c'est que les plus
anciens outils les plus anciens outils
enfin de la plus ancienne industries
lithiques est vieille de 3,3 millions
d'années donc elle est presque aussi
vieille
il est aussi vieille que l'uci qui est à
3,2 millions d'années alors que vous
avez le premier représentant du genre
homo qui est à 2,8 millions d'années
seulement
vous avez un énorme creux en fait entre
le premier outil est le premier roman
alors est ce que ça veut dire qu'il faut
appeler lui si un représentant du genre
homo
bah ça fout la merde le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est que ça fout la merde
donc on a un gros problème avec la
définition du genre homo et pour
l'instant il ya personne qui arrive à
faire émerger de consensus et l'une des
raisons pour ça c'est qu'en fait
personne pour l'instant ne s'était
penché sur la question de la phylogénie
donc parce que si on a un arbre
phylogénétique c'est beaucoup plus
facile de prendre des décisions
taxonomique de ce genre je vous renvoie
à ma vidéo sur sahelanthropus de ce
point de vue là j'en parlais déjà dans
la vidéo sur sahel entre opus c'est
quand on a un arbre phylogénétique c'est
toujours beaucoup plus simple de prendre
une décision de qu'est-ce qu'un homo et
qu'est-ce qui n'en est pas et donc c'est
ce qu'ils ont fait dans cette analyse et
c'est la grande contribution de cette
analyse il propose enfin une définition
du genre homo basé sur un arbre
phylogénétique donc une définition qui
sera beaucoup moins arbitraire beaucoup
moins arbitraire parce qu'elle est basée
sur la construction d'un arbre qui est
un
qui est une méthode reproductible qui
est une méthode méthode scientifiquement
testable et techniquement reproductible
c'est à dire que si deux personnes ne
sont pas d'accord sur la façon dont il
faut considérer un caractère et bien ces
deux personnes vont pouvoir codé ce
caractère différemment dans des arbres
phylogénétiques et regarder comment ça
impacte le résultat est accordé leur
définition du genre homo en fonction du
résultat est plus souvent que que pas
ben on va voir on va voir que les arbres
vont être exactement les mêmes quelle
que soit la façon dont le caractère est
codé donc finalement ça n'aura pas de
définition sur l'impact sur la décision
taxonomique de qu'est-ce qu'on inclut
dans le genre homo ou pas donc quand on
regarde une phylogénie canton quand on
regarde une phylogénie il ya trois
façons de définir en fait un
ce qu'on appelle un clad voilà c'est à
dire un groupe monofil éthiques
un groupe taxons quoi donc si on veut
définir le genre homo par exemple il ya
trois manières de le faire à partir d'un
arbre phylogénétique la première manière
c'est d'utiliser un caractère donc on va
choisir un caractère qui définit le
genre homo c'est ce qu'ont fait par
exemple bas pour les maliens forme donc
les mammifères le l'endroit où
s'arrêtent les reptiles malien et où
commencent les mammifères s'est défini
par un changement de caractère elle ce
changement de caractère c'est le
changement d'une mandibule reptilienne
enfin d'une articulation de la mâchoire
avec le crâne de type reptilienne à une
articulation de type mammalienne donc
entre deux les eaux sont différents en
fait les eaux qui forment l'articulation
de la mâchoire sont différents et ça ça
permet de tracer la limite entre ce
qu'on considère comme étant un mammifère
est ce qu'on considère comme n'étant pas
un mammifère
donc ça c'est une première façon des
jets de le faire et c'est plus ou moins
ce qu'on faisait déjà avant avec
justement la fabrication d'outils sauf
que le problème c'est que
l'applicabilité de ce truc là à part si
vous trouvez un homme a dominé avec un
outil dans la main en train de taper et
qui est mort comme ça il faut utiliser
comme ça l'applicabilité de ce truc là
lé 0
donc faut laisser tomber voilà donc la
deuxième façon de faire il ya une
deuxième façon de définir des clad donc
une deuxième façon qu'on pourrait
utiliser de définir le genre homo c'est
d'utiliser une espèce de se baser sur
une espèce c'est ce qu'ont fait par
exemple pour archéo pour les oiseaux
donc pour les oiseaux la définition des
oiseaux c'est archéoptéryx et toutes les
espèces qui sont plus proches
d'archaeopteryx que quelque chose
d'autre
voilà ça c'est la définition des oiseaux
enfin de aves du clad inverse et ça
marche relativement bien c'est
relativement stables tout ce qui est
plus proche de l'archaeopteryx va être
appelé un oiseau et tout ce qui n'est
pas directement branché archéoptéryx ne
sera pas considéré comme un oiseau voilà
et on avait fait ça alors cnf pour le
genre homo c'est ernst haïr qui avait
fait ça dans les années 50
c'est un grand chercheur
un grand biologiste ernst mailly qui a
qui est à la source de la théorie
synthétique de l'évolution voilà la
nouvelle
la nouvelle théorie de la théorie de neo
darwinienne de l'évolution s'est
globalement lui qui a chapeauté sa canne
smiles qui l'avait proposé c'est que
qu'on appelle aux mots qu'on appelle au
mot toutes les espèces qui sont plus
proches d'homo sapiens que du chimpanzé
voilà donc pour lui là si on regarde cet
arbre en fait tous ici devrait s'appeler
homos c'est à dire vu que là vous avez
homo sapiens qui est ici et que tout ici
est branché plus du côté homo sapiens
que du côté du chimpanzé qui se trouve
là bas tout ça ça devrait s'appeler
homos donc on aurait au mot ramidus home
au tchad n 6 au lieu de celle entre opus
tous les australopithèques la afarensis
garé en amène six seraient des homos
homo africanus homo robustus au lieu de
paranthropus robustus et ainsi de suite
voilà donc tout ça s'appellerait au
monde le problème de cette définition la
de la définition de homo là bas c'est
que l à la vente
enfin la désavantage d'appeler au mot
des trucs qui se ressemblent très peu au
final parce que bon c'est l'entreprise
challen 6 les australopithèques y
ressemble pas tant que ça au genre homo
je veux dire des bombes à la taille du
cerveau notamment est un caractère qui
joue énormément c'est vrai qu'on a du
mal à appeler aux maux des trucs qui ont
un petit cerveau mais faut faire gaffe
faut faire gaffe à la taille du cerveau
comme je voulais expliquer avec les deux
articles précédents la taille du cerveau
ne veut rien dire
on peut être homo et avoir un cerveau
qui s'est réduit voilà avoir un gros
cerveau à la base mais qui s'est ensuite
réduit donc la taille du cerveau c'est
pas forcément un caractère primitif qui
peut servir à la classification mais
bref on a un peu de mal du coup les
paléontologues les paléoanthropologues
ont un peu de mal avec cette définition
là parce que passé on appelle tous homos
et au final tout appelé avec le même nom
s'est au final autant de rien d'appeler
enfin si quitte à donner le même nom à
tout ça sert plus à rien quoi
ça permet plus de faire la différence
faut voir qu'une classification ses sens
et c'est de toute façon c'est arbitraire
quoi qu'il arrive et une classification
c'est censé être fait par les chercheurs
pour les chercheurs pour nous dire pour
qu'on s'est retrouvé en fait dans la
diversité des espèces éteintes
si tout porte le même nom on s'y
retrouve plus voilà donc ça plaît pas
voilà ça n'a pas plus à la sauce n'a pas
pris comme je voulais 10 avait été
proposée dans les années 50 et la sauce
n'a pas pris donc la dernière définition
c'est une définition basé sur les noeuds
donc une définition qui se base sur sur
ce qu'on retrouve à l'intérieur d'un
noeud alors un ne cessa par exemple donc
là par exemple le genre homo au sens
strict ici les définit comme étant bas
le le plus ancien ancêtre à homo sapiens
et aomori avec tus donc l'homo erectus
d'asie qui est le lot type finalement le
l'homme l'homme de java qui est le lot
type en fait d'homo erectus donc là le
genre homo au sens strict c'est
l'ancêtre ans l'ancêtre en commun d'homo
sapiens et d'homo erectus et tous leurs
descendants
donc là vous avez lancé être en commun
vous avez tous les descendants d'homo
sapiens de l'ancêtre en commun d'homo
sapiens et homo erectus qui forment le
genre homo sangsues stricto l'avantagent
de cette définition dont qui est proposé
ici dans cet article c'est que elle est
hyper stable le lire il ya aucun doute
sur le fait que tout ça on appelle ça du
genre homo
contrairement à la définition de jean
rondeau sans dessus la thau où là on
inclut homo habilis et homo floresiensis
pour lesquels il ya des débats sur faute
il les appelait au mot australopithèques
alors le problème des australopithèques
sait aussi que c'est un groupe comme
vous pouvez le voir qui est paraffine
éthiques voire même poliphile éthique
parce que là on a africanus qui se
baladent à côté de kenyans trop plus ici
on a sediba qui se baladent à côté de
mona lady est là vous avez encore trois
3 autres australopithèques qui se
baladent à la base de l'arbre donc par
australopithèques us c'est un truc qui
sert quasiment à rien qu en fait c'est
un ce qu'on appelle un taxon un peu
poubelle c'est tout ce qui n'est en gros
tout ce qu'il ya un trop petit cerveau
pour être rappelé aux mollahs on a envie
de l'appeler australopithecus esquissé
ce qui se passe avec homo habilis et
l'homo florensis c'est à dire que comme
ils ont un petit cerveau il ya plein de
paléo anthropologue qui veulent pas en
entendre parler et qu'ils disent annoncé
australopithèque et c'est tombé mais
encore une fois la taille du cerveau
ces deux articles la taille du cerveau
faut pas s'y fier faut pas s'y fier on
peut ça peut être un caractère dérivés
un petit cerveau donc faut faire
attention
donc voilà donc l'inconvénient donc
enfin l' avantage de coût de cette de
cette définition la du clad en bleu bah
c'est que justement elle exclut des
trucs qui sont débattues voilà en gros
donc là cette définition sans dessus
lato elle serait un peu plus discutable
mais elle a aussi l'avantagé d'inclure
homo habilis qui est quand même un jalon
de l'évolution humaine qu'on rencontre
fréquemment dans la littérature je veux
dire on connaît tous la série évolutive
australopithecus homo habilis homo
erectus et homo sapiens quoi donc
donc ce serait exclure du genre homo un
jalon important qui a été historiquement
considérée un port comme important dans
la littérature elle a un autre problème
cette définition rouge c'est qu'elle est
basée sur un cloud qui est soutenue que
par 44% de buddh strates je crois que
c'est du bullshit rappelé qu'ils ont
utilisés mais bref ça veut juste dire
que en gros
normalement on devrait même pas garder
un clad qui est soutenue avec 80% de
buddh strap
on devrait on devrait le transformer en
politique on devrait le détruire ce que
ladd et la la il garde un cloud qui à
moins de 50% donc généralement on a
quand on utilise des matrices
morphologiques qui inclut des que des
espèces fossiles
on a un seuil de tolérance qui tombe à
50 % au lieu de 80% de bootstrap mais là
en dessous de 50% devraient même pas
considérer ce club comme étant existants
quoi donc
un problème avec cette définition là
c'est que les très très mal soutenu quoi
et enfin vous avez un clac donc cette
fois à 54% donc il reste tolérable et
c'est la définition du genre homo cents
us en plo qui l'a inclus absolument tout
ce qu'on a un jour appelé au mot donc
aumône à lundi inclus
ça c'est une définition qui est
intéressante parce que elle ferait de
australopithecus sediba un membre du
genre homo
ce qui veut dire qu'elle déjà elle
résoudre est un petit peu le problème
d'australopithèques us poliphile
éthiques
en supprimant australopithecus sediba en
en faisant homo sediba donc ça au moins
ça aurait au moins l'avantagé cette
définition d'inclure tout ce qu'on a un
jour appelé au mot donc on mona lady
homo floresiensis homo habilis et en
plus d'éliminer un de ces
australopithèques us dont on sait que de
toute façon il faut arrêter de l'appeler
australopithecus parce que là c'est pas
australopithecus les australopithèques
us ils sont là voilà donc ça c'est trop
dériver australopithecus sediba il est
trop dériver il a des toutes petites
dents par exemple ça c'est un caractère
typiquement homos donc voilà donc moi
j'ai moi j'ai une préférence j'ai une
sérieuse préférence pour le genre homo
scène su en plo parce que justement il
supprime une partie du problème avec
australopithèques us et inclue tout ce
qu'on a appelé au mot donc voilà
maintenant ça y est ce serait fini et
maintenant tout ce qui est voilà à
chaque fois qu'on refera une nouvelle
analyse phylogénétique tout ce qui
tomberait à l'intérieur de ce noeud la
voilà on appellerait ça au mot et ce
qu'il tomberait à l'extérieur faudrait
voir si ça tombe par là ce sera un
parent trope donc ce qu'on appelait
autrefois les australopithèques robustes
et puis si ça tombe par là bas il va
falloir décider à faire du ménage dans
l'aude australopithèques avant de
l'appeler australopithèques pas ce que
c'est
c'est un peu le dawa fin à telle est
intéressant dans cette analyse
sahelanthropus tchadensis et plus
dérivés constant l'hôpital tu seras 1000
us c'est marrant c'est une analyse qui a
dix qui fait ça plusieurs fois mettre
des espèces plus jeune plus dérivés que
des espèces plus ancien ce qui est pas
interdit en soi c'est pas interdit de
mettre des espèces financer des espèces
plus anciennes qui sont plus des rives
et des espèces plus jeunes
c'est le contraire de ce que je m'aime
bien donc ça elle entre aux puces et
pluvieux costral au pit et qu'il sera
dit ramidus et pourtant on le trouve
plus haut dans l'arbre australopithèques
ardipithecus ramidus ouah je fatigue je
commence à fatiguer donc ça aide entre
opus normalement il a 5 millions
d'années ardipithecus il en a que six je
crois d'ailleurs je crois qu'il ya deux
arts dépité q si un hacker ainsi si on a
un qui est à 4 millions d'années
bref sahel entre eux plus est censé être
plus vieux donc on s'attend normalement
dans l'arbre phylogénétique à ce qu'ils
soient plus bas est pourtant là il est
plus dérivés et ça arrive plusieurs
autres fois avec d'autres espèces là par
exemple floridienne si ce qui est plus
en bas dans l'arbre que rudolf n 6 et
habilis qui sont pourtant beaucoup plus
anciens et puis ça arrive aussi là avec
le l'homo erectus africain qui est plus
ancien que l'homo erectus d'asie et qui
pourtant est pareil plus haut dans
l'arbre donc en fait c'est la série
inverse l'africain qui est plus jeune
enfin qui est plus dérivés que
l'asiatique qui est normalement plus
jeunes donc c'est ça arrive plusieurs
fois dans l'eure dans leur arbre il ya
peut-être un petit problème de polarité
de caractère qui serait responsable de
sa mort douleur voilà c'est mais encore
une fois il faut saluer le il faut
saluer la démarche qui est de enfin
regarder à la définition du genre homo
d'un point de vue philosophique éthique
et plus d'un point de vue arbitraire et
arrêter de arrêter d'y aller chacun de
sa petite opinion voilà il faut voir
c'est juste ça c'est pour lapointe c'est
la première fois qu'on essaie de donner
une définition genre homo qui est pas
juste basée sur des opinions de
spécialistes et ça c'est bien voilà
c'est pas juste voilà on suce le doigt
on voit dans quel côté le vent souffle
et puis c'est à quoi donc j'espère que
cela constituera la base de débat sur la
définition du genre homo qui seront
beaucoup beaucoup plus sain et beaucoup
plus scientifique surtout
on continue l'article suivant c'est un
article qui va faire polémique ou qui a
fait polémique parce que c'est un
article dans lequel les auteurs
affirment que homo sapiens est
primitivement un hyper carnivores alors
oui les vegan engueuler et je vous ai vu
je vous ai vu sur ma page sur twitter en
train de gueuler mais oui mais c'est pas
moi qui le dit c'est l'article donc
qu'est ce qui dit cet article qu'est-ce
qu'il dit cet article va on va on va y
passer un petit moment on va y passer un
petit moment parce que je suis pas
fondamentalement d'accord avec tout ce
qu'il dit j'ai eu beau le partager sur
la page twitter parce que j'aime bien
les débats et j'aime bien quand quand on
a des opinions provocante comme ça mais
il est vrai que quand on analyse le fond
du bouddha bas il ya quand même des gros
problèmes dans cet article alors alors
déjà on va on va tout de suite calmé
justement les vegan et l'écart nist et
les gens qui ont un régime paléo si on a
encore le régime alimentaire en c'est
strahl du genre on nous voilà la
question du régime alimentaire
ancestrale du genre bon déjà j'ai abordé
la question dans une autre vidéo
mais de toute façon vous avez tous
raison et vous avez tous tort c'est à
dire que l'écart nist il aimerait bien
qu'on soit tous carnivores enfin que le
régime ancestrale des homininés soit
carnivores si vous regardez dans
l'évolution humaine il ya des carnivores
un homo erectus
il n'y a pas vraiment de débat sur le
fait qu' au moins y tue s'était
légèrement omnivore intendance
franchement carnivore il ya une raison
toute simple à ça c'est parce que homo
erectus
il vivait en même temps qu'une autre
espèce enfin qu'un autre grand groupe
d'hominidés qui étaient les parents trop
puces et qui eux étaient franchement
franchement herbivores voilà donc il y
avait une partition des ressources ce
qu'on appelle une partition écologique
des niches
d'un côté les parents trope qui étaient
à bord et de l'autre côté les homo
erectus qui était franchement carnivores
et on va le voir dans cet article après
ça ça encore changer pour devenir un peu
plus omnivore chez homo sapiens mais
c'était déjà relativement omnivore avant
la partition entre part entre opus est
homo erectus
c'était déjà relativement haut niveau à
tendance plutôt herbivores chez les
australopithèques et encore avant ça si
vous remonter encore plus loin dans le
temps vous allez trouver des choses
franchement herbivores parce que on
arrive avec un autre ancêtre en commun
avec les grands singes et que les grands
singes sont tous herbivores gorilles et
chimpanzés et orangs-outans ils sont
tous herbivores donc notre ancêtre avec
eux étaient forcément hyper herbivore
quoi donc vous avez tous raison il ya
une il ya une énorme
en fait il ya une énorme confusion dans
le terme omnivore aussi c'est qu'il ya
une différence entre omnivore et
généraliste un généraliste doit manger
de tout un omnivore peut manger de tout
et ça ça fait une énorme différence
ça fait une énorme différence et la
subtilité est pas si évidente que ça
donc il ya les gens qui vont vous dire
que l'être humain est donc un omnivore
parce qu'il mange de tout mais est ce
que le l'être humain est un généraliste
doit-il manger de tout et c'est là en
fait qu'il ya un énorme débat entre
entre justement les vegan et les paléo
d'aillet télé car nice tu es tout ça l
être humain doit-il manger de tout ça la
réponse que les gens qui ont écrit cet
article apporté que non l'être humain
est un hyper carnivores voilà donc
l'être humain ne doit pas manger de tout
mais il faut faire on va dire que mon
opinion personnelle c'est qu'il faut
éviter de faire des généralisations
abusives et l'être humain a beau être
une seule et unique espèces ce que je ne
remets pas en question il faut pas non
plus négliger les variations de
population à savoir que les inuit par
exemple s'en sortent très bien sans la
moindre bout de sans le moindre bout de
végétation de quoi que ce soit dans le
bref faut déjà faut éviter quand on
parle du régime alimentaire ancestrale
d'homo sapiens va falloir déjà se mettre
d'accord sur le fait qu'on parle
strictement d'homo sapiens et pas des
voix là parce que n'importe quel point
vous vous situez dans la phylogénie du
des homininés vous pouvez trouver soit
des carnivores soit d'herbivores soit
des omnivores
donc il faut bien se mettre d'accord
qu'on va parler que d'homo sapiens mais
surtout faut faire attention au fait
qu'on ne parle que de l'état ancestrale
d'homo sapiens est pas et que ça n'a
aucune sorte d' implication sur les
humains d'aujourd'hui il ne faut pas
généraliser ces résultats aux humains
d'aujourd'hui les humains d'aujourd'hui
sont une entité différente des humains
d'il ya trois cent mille ans des humains
près néolithique notamment et donc les
populations qui ont connu la révolution
néolithique désormais ont des
adaptations indéniable à l'herbe ivory
les amylase notamment un exemple très
très connue c'est les amylase voilà ça
c'est une adaptation à l'herbe ivory
l'amidon c'est pas dans la viande qu'on
le trouve donc les humains qui ont subi
la révolution néolithique il ya eu une
sélection naturelle dantesque sur eux et
maintenant ils ont des adaptations ils
sont plus
omnivore que ceux qui n'ont pas subi
cette révolution néolithique par exemple
les inuit
voilà donc ça faut bien le faut bien se
le fourrer dans la tronche quelque part
que la condition ancestrale d'homo
sapiens ou de quel que soit le mini dès
que vous choisissez n'a aucune incidence
sur sur le débat homo sapiens
d'aujourd'hui les populations
d'aujourd'hui devrait l être
carnivores ou herbivore où que je sois
voit la fin de fin de la parenthèse
attaquons l'article donc cette article
nous dit en gros il nous annonce qu'il
va étudier le niveau trophique d'homo
sapiens donc des humains donc le niveau
trophique ça veut dire herbivores
carnivores ou généraliste ou omnivore va
essayer de déterminer en fait si l'être
humain quel est le niveau trophique de
l'être humain où est ce qu'il est dans
la chaîne alimentaire
c'est exactement ça que ça veut dire on
préfère pas parler de niveaux trophiques
parce que c'est plus une pyramide qu'une
chaîne en réalité ce n'est même plus un
réseau d'ailleurs qu'une pyramide enfin
bref c'est beaucoup plus compliqué une
simple chaîne mais pour faire simple on
va dire c'est la position de l'être
humain dans la chaîne alimentaire et
pour ça ils vont faire une grande revue
de la littérature donc ils vont observer
toutes les sources
ils vont observer les sources publiées
et faire un peu comme une méta-analyse
si vous connaissez le terme et vont
faire un peu comme une méta-analyse
c'est-à-dire compilé toutes les sources
a essayé de faire un grand bilan d'en
tirer un grand bilan de où est-ce que
homo sapiens se tient dans la chaîne
alimentaire par rapport à tout ce qui a
déjà été publié
donc il développe toute une quantité
d'arguments issue de cette littérature
qui est résumé dans leur tableau 1 qui
se trouve tout à la fin de l'article
parce que pourquoi faire simple pourquoi
mettre le tableau 1 au début de
l'article quand on peut le mettre
total à fin dans sept tableaux 2 mais
bref quand même le tableau 2 qui à la
page 16 d'un article de 30 pages c'est
quand même un peu fort de café mais bref
donc il développe tout un tas
d'arguments issue de cette littérature
qui sont résumées ici et alors le et
j'ai plusieurs problèmes avec cet
article
donc c'est l'instant gros sel l'instant
gros sel qui commence dès maintenant
j'ai plusieurs problèmes avec cet
article parce que cet article il va
conclure que l'être humain est un hyper
carnivores donc ce que l'article nous
dit c'est que nous avons regardé la
littérature sur le régime alimentaire
d'homo sapiens d'épreuves qui viennent à
la fois comme vous le voyez de la
biologie qui nous viennent à la fois de
l'archéologie de la paléontologie
et de la génétique et tout ça des
isotopes
donc bref on a regardé on a ratissé très
large et de toute cette littérature ce
qu'on en tire c'est que l'être humain
est un hyper carnivores mêmes c'est un
superprédateur puisqu'il est capable de
manger d'autres prédateurs donc l'être
humain il est capable de chasser de tuer
de manger d'autres prédateurs et il est
hyper karnik donc c'est un super
prédateur et c'est un hyper carnivores
parce que ils mangent beaucoup plus de
viande que du reste et là j'ai un énorme
problème là j'ai un énorme problème
encore une fois un primitivement
aujourd'hui ça ne s'applique plus mais
primitivement l'humain quand il est
apparu homo sapiens quand il est apparu
était un hyper carnivores et je crois
qu'il généralise aussi au genre oh non
et là j'ai un énorme problème avec ça
parce que c'est un problème
méthodologique en fait c'est que oui ils
ont fait une grande revue de la
littérature mais pas de toutes les
preuves
ils ont fait une grande revue de la
littérature à propos de la carne ivory
chez l'homme ils n'ont pas regardé tous
les articles
ils n'ont pas regardé tous les articles
qui parlait du régime alimentaire chez
l'homme ils ont regardé tous les
articles qui parlait de la carne ivory
chez l'homme donc ils sont incapables de
dire à quel point l'être humain manger
autre chose que de la viande puisqu'il
ne regardait que les articles qui
parlait de l'être humain en tant que
consommateur de viande
donc ils sont incapables de déterminer
le niveau trophique de l'être humain ils
n'ont regardé qu'un seul aspect ils ont
regardé qu'un seul bout de la lorgnette
ils ont pas regarder l'autre bout donc
comment ils peuvent déterminer et je le
sais qu'ils n'ont pas regardé toute la
littérature parce qu'il manque cet
article là notamment article qui est
sorti l'année dernière donc un an avant
leurs articles de leurs articles et
extrêmement récent il est sorti en 2021
celui là il est sorti en 2009 en janvier
2020 si je me rappelle bien c'est la
date de publication de se trouver
quelque part mais peu importe il est
sorti en 2000 23 juin 3 janvier 2020
voilà donc il est sorti il ya un an donc
il est très récent donc il n'y a pas de
raison de le rater et il est antérieure
leur article donc ya pas de raison ne
pas l'avoir lu et pourtant il n'est pas
cité dans leur article
pourtant il n'y ait pas cité est
effondré cet article il dit que les
humains consommer de l'amidon il ya 170
mille ans les 170 mille ans d bien avant
la révolution néolithique
on est la révolution néolithique elle a
dix mille ans environ on va là situé à
dix mille ans juste pour faire simple
170000 en est largement avance à 1
on n'est encore sûr de l'homo sapiens
anatomiquement archaïque à ce moment là
donc homo sapiens mangeait déjà de
l'amidon alors des petites racines voyez
des racines qui ressemble à ça qu'il
faisait cuire et qu'il consommait donc
on a une preuve on a cette preuve la
soixante dix mille ans dans une grotte
qui s'appelle la border km mais il ya
aussi d'autres exemples qui ont été
faits qui ont été trouvés dans une autre
grotte qui s'appelle la grotte de classe
i river qui ont 120 mille ans donc c'est
en plus c'est pas des genre d'épreuve
isolé un pour vous prouver même que
c'est pas des preuves isolé là il ya un
article alors qui est tout récent suis
là par contre il ya aucune chance qu'il
l'ait vu puisqu'il est sorti même après
leurs articles à eux donc c'est aussi
une news on va dire en gros c'est une
étude où ils ont étudié le microbiome à
l'intérieur de la bouche des des êtres
humains et ils ont inclus des hommes de
néanderthal dans le paquet parce que
voilà il vous avez le tartre sur les
dents et se tarte qui l'emprisonnent des
bactéries les bactéries qui était
commune dans la bouche des êtres humains
du passé donc on peut séquencer l'adn de
ces bactéries même des milliers d'années
après parce que l'adn est encore là donc
dans le tartre de l'homme de néandertal
donc un être humain qui est
classiquement imaginer comme étant un
chasseurs de grand gibier est un hyper
carnivores pour le coup la peau trop de
débats sur le fait que néandertal est
considéré comme un hyper carnivores et
bien dans le tartre de néandertal ils
ont retrouvé des petits streptocoque
voilà ce que j'ai mis ce que je verrai
il a été ici ils ont retrouvé des petits
streptocoque qui se nourrissent d'amis
dont ils ne se nourrissent que d'amidon
donc ces petits streptocoques ils n'ont
pu survivre dans la bouche des
néandertaliens que si les néandertaliens
consommer aussi de l'amidon donc
consommer des tubercules par exemple des
petits tubercules exactement comme comme
cela voilà donc cela il en plus ils sont
très communs en afrique donc on sait que
les populations modernes les consomme
mais voilà ça peut être des tubercules
ça peut être des feuilles ça peut être
des fruits ça peut être n'importe quoi
mais voilà on sait que merde du coup ça
suggère que néandertal consommer des dés
de l'amidon aussi de donc de l'amidon
issu du coup deux de végétaux
donc même néandertal qu'on imagine être
un hyper carnivores n'est pas voilà il
faut quand même prendre en compte qu'il
ya une certaine dimension végétale à ça
à son régime alimentaire et du coup ça
suggère sachant que c'est les mêmes
streptocoques qu'on retrouve aujourd'hui
chez homo sapiens ça suggère que
l'ancêtre en commun la de homo sapiens
et néandertal qui vivait il ya 600 mille
ans environ eh ben ils consommaient
aussi déjà une quantité non négligeable
de d'amidon ce qu'il faut voir que pour
que ces bactéries change il faut quand
même que la quantité d'amidon soit non
négligeable pour que ces petits
streptocoques puisse survivre
donc voilà donc on sait que ce n'est pas
anecdotique ce genre de ce genre de
découverte non seulement parce qu'on en
a fait plusieurs mais aussi parce qu'il
ya cet article en plus ce qui rajoute
que voilà il et les bactéries étaient
capables de survivre grâce à l'ami donc
au sommet néanderthal et les homo
sapiens anciens archaïque
bon bref et c'est tout ça ça c'est
complètement absent dans cet article
alors il ya quelques mentions de garde
autre article qui ont proposé un régime
alimentaire différents mais comme j'ai
dit c'est seulement dans nos rues ils
n'ont passé en revue que les articles
qui parlent de karni vori et pas les
autres
donc les articles comme celui là qui
propose qui parle pas du tout car
nouveau riz pour le coup qui disent
juste vous voyez on a en a quand même un
registre archéologique de dôme niveau
riche et homo sapiens donc bref
donc ça c'est le premier gros problème
leur revue de la littérature ne permet
pas c'est pas qu'elle ait pas complète
c'est pas qu'ils ont mal fait leur
boulot c'est juste que leur revue de la
littérature ne permet pas de conclure ce
qu il conclu
on peut pas conclure à une hyper
carnivores ici on a regardé que le côté
carnivores et ils ont regardé que le
côté carnivores ils ont regardé que la
littérature qui parle de karni vori donc
on peut pas conclure qu'ils aillent père
carnivores ici on regarde que la moitié
de du problème donc c'est là c'est leur
conclusion avec laquelle j'ai un
problème pas leur façon de faire et en
plus bas après il ya effectivement un
problème avec leur façon de faire je
trouve notamment parce qu'il ya certains
arguments qui sont extrêmement simpliste
notamment l'argument sur le cerveau donc
chez les primates voilà un plus gros
cerveau c'est forcément ça va forcément
de pair avec plus d'énergie
donc voilà des graisses et des protéines
donc encore cette fameuse histoire de
les graisses les protéines c'est ça qui
a permet au cerveau de grossir chez les
êtres humains mais ça sort d'où encore
une fois ça parce qu'en plus il cite
même pas la source pour ça pour le coup
j'ai regardé ici tu m'aimes pas de
source pour ça ça sort d'où cette
histoire que le cerveau a absolument
besoin de graisse et de protéines pour
pour augmenter de taille
alors oui je veux bien qu'il faut
abreuver l'embryon de graisses et de
protéines pour qu'ils puissent
construire l'organe cerveau mais pas
plus que pas plus de graisses et de
protéines qu'il n'en faut pour
construire un rein pour construire un
temps créa ou des poumons
je pense pas qu'un g de cerveau soit
plus compliqué à construire face coûte
plus cher en protéines et en grèce à
construire que cas fois où 15 1
par contre ce qui coûte cher au
fonctionnement du cerveau c'est le passé
de le faire fonctionner construire le
cerveau le cerveau arrivé à trois ans il
est construit c'est fini une fois que
vous avez 3 ans votre cerveau a
quasiment atteint sa taille adulte
le cerveau ne grossis presque plus après
ça ait aucune cellules du cerveau ou
presque aucune du cellules du cerveau ne
va se renouveler c'est aussi important à
prendre en compte ça c'est qu'on pourra
dire ben oui mais après il faut
l'alimenter pour que les continue pour
que ça continue de se diviser il faut
l'alimenter en protéines et en grèce
pour que ça se divise
maintenant les cellules les neurones ne
se divise pas ou très très peu
et à chaque fois qu'on découvre qu'un
euro ne s'est divisé on en fait une
publication scientifique totalement
c'est un événement
je veux dire donc évidemment vous allez
me donner des contre exemples de
publication qui disent que les neurones
se divisent mais oui mais c'est
précisément parce que c'est hyper rare
de voir des neurones se diviser que que
qu'on en fait des publications
scientifiques c'est autrement les
neurones ça ne se divise pas en tout cas
pas après justement pas après trois ans
donc
donc c'est pas la maintenance qui coûte
cher la maintenance bas ça va être
remplacé des acides aminés par ci par là
mais voilà c'est pas la maintenance qui
coûte cher ce qui coûte cher c'est le
fonctionnement et le fonctionnement
c'est du sucre du sucre du sucre alors
vous pouvez obtenir vos sucre par la
grèce j'en conviens
c'est quand même vachement plus facile
de les obtenir grâce à de l'amidon est
d'ailleurs le et je suis pas le seul à
le dire parce que cet article là et
c'est une autre raison pour laquelle je
les mines à cet article la celui qui est
sorti tout récemment la sur les
streptocoques il rappelle que justement
si aumône aussi l'homme de néandertal et
son ancêtre en commun avec homo sapiens
consommer de l'amidon ça a peut-être
joué un rôle fondamental dans le
développement du cerveau en l'alimentant
en sucre justement et là je suis content
parce que je suis pas le seul à le dire
parce que c'est pas la première fois que
je le dis
des bordels pourquoi pourquoi le qu'elle
est là quelle est l'importance des
protéines et de la grèce dans le
développement du cerveau quoi je suis
d'accord que le régime alimentaire doit
être riche mais riches en sucres ou en
graisses et en protéines et là il nous
ravit nous rabâche encore une fois que
c'est la grèce et la protéine la grèce
et les protéines qui vont aider à faire
grossir le cerveau non je vois pas
pourquoi il n'y a pas de raison ce qui
coûte cher dans le cerveau c'est son
fonctionnement c'est le sucre qu'ils
consomment pour fonctionner donc c'est
tout à fait compatible avec un régime
alimentaire herbivores et les d'ailleurs
les éléphants ne s'y sont pas trompés
les éléphants ils ont un énorme cerveau
même comparé au poids de leur corps pas
seulement en taille absolue mais même
comparé à leur corps les éléphants ont
un gros cerveau et savent à quoi ils
sont très intelligents se boit plus con
que la moyenne
il ya beaucoup d'oiseaux qui sont
herbivores et qui sont très intelligents
aussi les perroquets par exemple le
perroquet là ça mange des fruits
principalement je pense que les
perroquets dirait pas non à une cuisse
une fois de temps en temps une petite
cuisses de grenouilles ou lézards
mais bref en tout cas voilà c'est
principalement des herbivores et
pourtant les perroquets sont extrêmement
intelligents pour des oiseaux et même
même d'ailleurs selon des standards de
primates un bref donc déjà il ya des
dons qu'il ya des arguments qui sont
simples je vais pas faire la revue de
tous les arguments parce que ça
prendrait des plombes là vous voyez la
taille du tableau mais juste voilà je
vais vous prendre des exemples qui sont
très marquant donc voilà il ya
l'argument de il ya des arguments qui
sont simplistes il ya des arguments qui
sont circulaires il ya un moment où il
nous parle de de la chasse en meute
c'est à dire que ont séché les
prédateurs que plus le groupe est grand
plus il consomme de viande
donc comme les êtres humains vivent en
groupe
gigantesque eh ben ils consomment
beaucoup de viande donc c'est donc cédé
hyper peur d hyper carnivores ben oui
mais enfin
encore une fois le raisonnement et
circulaires dans le sens où il faut déjà
de base avoir admis que les êtres
humains sont des prédateurs pour dire
que leurs groupes leur meute est très
grande et donc plus leur note est grande
plus ils consomment de la viande
donc c'est un argument qui est
complètement circulaire l'être humain
est un prédateur dont qui consomment
beaucoup de viande donc il est carnivore
ouais donc ça c'est pareil si vous le
cherchez vous le trouverez cet argument
là hein c'est un argument je crois qu'il
est aux logiques
il ya une catégorie éthologique quelque
part voilà ethnographie où ça doit être
quelque part là dedans mais bref vous le
trouverez cet argument il et vous verrez
que j'exagère pas c'est vraiment ça qui
disent c'est la taille de la meute chez
les prédateurs et qu'on est corrélé à la
quantité de viande qu'ils mangent ce qui
semble logique mais faut admettre de
base qu'on est face à un prédateur
or c'est la question justement la
question et at on affaire à un prédateur
ou pas avec l'être humain
et voilà si vous avez déjà la réponse
avant de commencer la question c'est un
raisonnement circulaire
donc voila et puis il ya un moment où
c'est aussi dans la catégorie
d'ethnographie oui louis le où ils
disent un peu d'aller se faire [ __ ]
principe d' actualiser parce que je
trouve assez problématique pour des
archéologues parce que c'est des
archéologues qui ont écrit cet article
c'est qu'en gros il dise alors on a les
données ethnographiques moderne donc les
données sur les sur les chasseurs
cueilleurs d'aujourd'hui qui nous montre
que ces chasseurs cueilleurs sont plutôt
généraliste donc fortement omnivore pour
dire autrement
donc ce sont plutôt des généralistes il
mange de tout et il faut qu'ils mangent
de tout à part les inuit évidemment à
part les inuits qui sont des chasseurs
cueilleurs qui sont strictement
chasseurs quoi mais bref les chasseurs
cueilleurs cédant leur nom ils sont
chasseurs ils sont cueilleurs il mange
de tout c'est quasiment un pléonasme
donc c'est en gros ce qu'ils disent
c'est que oui mais ces données
ethnographiques ne sont pas ne sont pas
forcément applicable à homo sapiens
archaïque qui était aussi qui est aussi
considérée comme étant autrefois comme
étant un chasseur cueilleur du coup donc
non en fait
homo sapiens archaïque n'était peut-être
pas forcément un chasseur cueilleur
comme homo sapiens a comme l'homo
sapiens moderne peut être un chasseur
cueilleur bah oui mais enfin si tu si tu
dis aux principes d'actual isme d'aller
se faire voir il te reste quoi c'est à
dire j'ai rien contre le fait de faire
des hypothèses qui veut dire la nature
actuelle et suffisamment diverses pour
qu'on puisse imaginer que la nature dans
le passé était encore plus diverses et
que du coup il ya des choses qui
existait autrefois qui n'ont pas de deux
représentants actuels aujourd'hui qui ne
sont pas représentés dans la nature
actuelle
je veux bien l'admettre ça le problème
c'est qu'à partir du moment où tu fais
cette hypothèse là bas tu ouvre la porte
à toutes les fenêtres à savoir que ben
web et tout devient possible du coup si
on peut plus si le principe d'
actualiser n'est plus là pour borner la
réflexion
bah tout devient possible qu'elle veut
dire l être humain
l'être humain savaient voler le dire
dans ce cas là il ya trois cent mille
ans pour moi le contraire voilà on entre
dans un système de réflexion si on se
passe du principe d' actualiser on entre
dans la système de réflexion de type
prouvez moi le contraire voilà et
eh ben on trouvera jamais et puis voilà
donc voilà les trois gros problème que
j'ai avec le raisonnement qui est
développé dans cet article est donc du
coup pour moi la conclusion l'être
humain était un hyper carnivores lé
daube et à mon avis l'être humain était
comme je les dis à répéter dans la
dernière vidéo là sur l'évolution
humaine c'est un omnivore attendant ce
carnivore voilà évolution qui lui vient
du coût de cette partition des niches
écologiques qui a eu lieu à l'époque
avec part entre opus donc pas rentrer
opus qui vivait à l'époque d'homo
erectus part entre opus était un super
herbivore et du coup bas il ya une
partition des niches écologiques entre
parents trop puce est homo erectus à
l'époque où ils vivaient ensemble
et du coup l'être humain moderne a
hérité un régime omnivore intendance
plutôt carnivore de son ancêtre homo
erectus est ce qu'il ya d'intéressant
par contre avec cet article
en plus du fait qu'ils que les
comparaisons dans cet article sont fait
d'une façon très intéressante puisque ça
nous ramène vraiment un autre condition
animale à savoir que c'est vraiment
l'être humain envisagé comme un animal
est il adapté à un régime alimentaire
carnivores donc ça c'est plutôt
intéressant
ça rappelle très bien que l'être humain
est finalement sujets aux mêmes
adaptation que les autres mammifères que
voilà la sélection naturelle
elle marche pareil chez l'être humain
pour ceux qui en doutaient encore
mais surtout ce que j'aime bien c'est
cette ce graphique là qu'il a pour le
coup être un résultat qui est cohérent
avec ce qu'ils essayent de avec leur
façon de faire c'est à dire que en fin
du mois si on regarde la colonne de
gauche donc c'est la colonne de gauche
c'est toutes les adaptations à la carne
ivory la colonne de droite cds
adaptation à ce qu'ils appellent à une
position trophique plus basse mais comme
ils n'ont pas regardé la littérature
pour ça on peut pas vraiment conclure
sur cette colonne de droite mais la
colonne de gauche par contre ces
adaptations à la carne ivory et en fait
ce qu'on constate c'est que cette
colonne de gauche elle se rétrécit quand
on passe d'homo erectus et homo sapiens
archaïque à homo sapiens
du paléolithique supérieur donc presque
juste avant la révolution néolithique
quoi donc on constate que les
adaptations à la carne ivory tact et est
la date et ben elles se réduisent
en fait il ya de moins en moins
d'adaptation à dakar niveau rit parce
que l'être humain s'adapte de plus en
plus un régime riche en face à l'ab de
plus en plus un régime qui inclut des
protéines d'origine végétale
enfin des protéines végétales et de
l'amidon et c'est donc par exemple
notamment les rhizomes dont on a parlé
tout à l'heure à un moment il parle
aussi des outils dans le registre
archéologiques donc qui à partir de
quarante mille ans on a de plus en plus
d'outils qui servent à couper des fibres
végétales
alors c'est intéressant comme argument
donc pour eux ça veut dire que encore
une fois l'être humain était hyper
carnivores avant mais enfin quarante
mille ans on n'est toujours pas la
révolution néolithique il ya quarante
mille ans on est trente mille ans avant
la révolution néolithique donc ça veut
dire que déjà trente mille ans avant la
révolution et néolithique on avait des
outils adaptés à découper de la fibre
végétale
après vous pourrez toujours me dire ça
pouvait servir à faire des paniers des
chapeaux mais c'est probable c'est très
probable que ça ait servi à faire là
pour la nourriture quoi donc
donc voilà on a une adaptation à l'herbe
ivory qui est un peu plus anciennes qui
est un peu plus ancienne que la
révolution néolithique déjà et donc ça
se reflète bien justement dans la baisse
en fait de la quantité d'adaptation
qu'on a là car niveau riz qu'il constate
ici et à mon avis leur méthodologie est
adéquat pour constater cette réduction
donc l'adaptation en fait à l'herbe
ivory elle en fait il démontre
finalement que l'adaptation à l'herbe
ivory est plus ancienne que ce qu'ils
disent qu'ils allaient pas néolithique
elle a déjà commencé avant ça donc voilà
c'est un article vous pouvez le lire
cette figure là je ne la comprends même
pas donc je vais pas la commenter
j'ai beau le dire je n'arrive pas à la
comprendre mais bref c'est un article
que vous pouvez lire qui est
relativement intéressant j'ai appris
quelques trucs notamment que les ténias
c'était en fait des parasites de
carnivores donc les ténias vous avez on
les obtient du boeuf et du porc mais
dans le boeuf et le port ils sont pas
sous forme de thénia ils sont sous forme
d'oeuf c'est la forme c'est la forme
infectieuses en fait la forme de verre
du ténia elle n'est elle ne se développe
que chez le carnivore qui mange le boeuf
et le port ce qui inclut les êtres
humains donc ça c'était intéressant et
si c'est vrai si ça s'applique
effectivement à tous les ténias c'est
une information que je trouve assez
intéressante
g car karner si tu regarde cette vidéo
tu pourra certainement le confirmer ou
l'infirmer voilà et puis il ya le il y
avait une autre information intéressante
c'était sur les c'était sur l'acidité
stomacale où l acidité stomacale de
l'être humain qui est donc un estomac
extrêmement acide de l'ordre de 2 un
péage de 2 voire même inférieur à ça je
le crois c'est plus acide que du
vinaigre et ça c'est une acidité qu'on
ne retrouve alors c'est pas que chez les
carnivores c'est même pire que ça c'est
une acidité qu'on ne retrouve que chez
les charognards et ça sert à ça quand on
remet sans lumière de ce qu'on dit des
homo erectus et de pourquoi et de et que
homo erectus
ils ont d'abord commencé à être des
charognards avant d'être des chasseurs
actifs
c'est intéressant de remettre ça en
lumière de ça parce que du coup ça ça
s'emboîte ça s'emboîte tous les
arguments l'air de s'emboîter ben oui si
on a un estomac de charognards quoi on a
un estomac qui est fait pour digérer
l'os et surtout tuer des bactéries de la
viande faisandée ce que notre notre
estomac c'est un champ droit de là un
grand chaudron de la mort pour les
bactéries qu'on ingère donc du coup et
puis les parasites aussi d'ailleurs
mais voilà donc c'est plutôt intéressant
en fait il ya déjà beaucoup de choses
intéressantes dans cet article mais faut
pas perdre de vue que à mon avis c'est
un article à charge c'est un article qui
est fait pour démontrer qu'on est des
carnivores c'est pas un article qui est
parti c'est pas un article les auteurs
sont partis en disant on va voir si
l'être humain est un carnivore ou un
herbivore c'est un article ou les
auteurs sont partis bille en tête
on va démontrer que l'être humain est un
carnivore et qu'il a ensuite et qu'il
s'est ensuite adapté à un régime plus à
revivre ce qui à mon avis est
relativement bien illustré par cette
figure la même si encore une fois la
colonne de droite l'aller elle est
incomplète elle est très très très très
très incomplète
voilà et pour terminer ce paléo news on
va finir avec des invertébrés parce que
chaque fois je néglige les invertébrés
et que la dernière fois les nos amis
invertébrés east ont fait du raffut en
commentaire en dix ans et on est là ils
ont fait du bruit voilà comme je leur
avais demandé à donc donc ils se sont
manifestés ils sont là donc on va leur
en donner un petit peu pour leur argent
quand même en parlant de belém need est
alors encore une fois cela c'est du très
récent là pour le coup ce vous avez
certainement vu passer la semaine
dernière voir cette semaine
nous sommes nous sommes le 16 quand
j'enregistre sage je suis le 16 mai 2021
et donc vous avez certainement vu passer
cette news qui est la découverte d'un
crustacé en train de se faire manger par
une belle et bénite en train de se faire
manger par un requin donc une chaîne
alimentaire complète fossilisés datant
du jurassique et bien cette news est un
petit peu exagéré pour pas dire
complètement fausse
donc en fait ce qu'ils ont découvert ce
que les auteurs ont découvert donc
encore une fois assez le thème de ce
paléo news c'est des trucs qui ont été
survendus par la presse c'est le grand
thème du paléo news c'est la presse a
merdé survendu des trucs voilà est donc
là on vous sur vend un fossile de
bédénik en train de manger un crustacé
est en train de se faire manger par un
requin donc voici le fossile de belém
dit ici vous avez le rostre est ici en
fait ce que vous voyez ce sont les
tentacules des deux labels et munich qui
est qui ont disparu mais qui ont laissé
derrière elles quand même les petits
crochets qui était qui accompagnait les
ventouses
il y avait des petits crochets en même
temps que les ventouses sur les
tentacules de la baie limites et du coup
ces petits crochets sont préservés ce
qui nous permet de voir où était la
bouche est donc là dans les tentacules
de la baie les mythes en fait ce qu'on
arrive à voir si je zoome un peu ici
voilà va vous voyez les deux passent ici
une pince là une pince là et puis un
petit peu un bout là d un genre de
crustacés vent qui est illustré juste la
voilà donc on voit un crustacé pris dans
les dents les tentacules de notre belle
et me dit voilà donc ce crustacé est en
train de se faire manger par l'abbé les
minutes par contre j'ai envie de dire où
est leur qu'un point d'interrogation
baraka il n'est pas la leur cas et les
deux figures plus loin il est ici alors
d'une ce n'est pas un requin sa libre
dont tu parce que la presse nous nous
vend nous vend un requin venger une
veillée munich qui a mangé un crustacé
mais non c'est pas un requin c'est un
niveau donc les hiboux routes ne sont
pas encore des requins
au même sens que les requins
d'aujourd'hui sont des requins par
contre ce sont des poissons
cartilagineux comme vous pouvez le voir
voyez que la l'epic qui sont aussi fier
eux sont pas du tout de la même couleur
que le cartilage ici qui lui n'était pas
aussi fier avec les belles et minitel
sont en relief par rapport aux
cartilages parce que pareil c'est c'est
du solide les rostre de belém need donc
là vous voyez un gros paquet de mêlée
minutes dans l'estomac de notre de notre
hymne aux deux gros paquets de belém dit
ici l'abbé limite que je vous ai montré
au-dessus n'en fait pas partie donc
pourquoi la presse at elle déclaré qu on
a retrouvé un niveau dont tu en train de
manger une belle denise en train de
manger un crustacé
je me le demande alors le libre dont il
vient du même gisement il est du même
âge et tout mais bon je veux dire ça
veut pas dire que c'est lui qui a croqué
la baie limite alors eu les les auteurs
font l'hypothèse que effectivement la
baie les min tit ci a été croquée par un
niveau dont tous enfin un requin ou un
prédateur quoi mais il ya aucune dent
ici qui est préservée qui pourrait
témoigner que c'est bien de qui est
l'auteur de cette morsure quoi donc ces
voix là c'est encore une fois un peu
abusif de dire qu'on avait toute une
chaîne alimentaire préservé comme ça
préservé comme ça dans le dans le
registre fossile on a des chaînes
alimentaires qui sont préservés dans le
registre fossile
hélas pas pour homo sinon ça aurait
beaucoup aidé les auteurs de l'article
précédent mais on a par exemple je crois
que c'est un mais celle qu'on a un
serpent qu'il a mangé une musaraigne ou
quelque chose comme ça un petit
mammifère qui lui même a des petits
bouts d'insectes de carapace de
coléoptères dans son estomac
donc on a le fossile du serpent à
l'intérieur on a le fossile du
la musaraigne enfin du petit mammifère
est lui même à l'intérieur dans son
estomac préserver à un petit bout de
carapace de d'insectes de coléoptères
donc là on a une chaîne alimentaire
entière puis préserver préservé tel quel
mais là c'est pas le cas là c'est pas le
cas donc c'est encore une fois c'est
comme j'ai dit c'est la thématique c'est
abusif par contre là le gros intérêt de
cet article c'est de nous montrer des
fossiles très très très très bien
préservés enfin vous voyez quand même
avoir un fossile comme ça avec du
cartilage préservé avec le contenu
stomacal préserver et préserver de cette
façon je veux dire là il n'y a vraiment
pas de doute sur l'interprétation du
contenu stomacal il est là c'est bon on
en est sûr il est complètement bardé de
belém dit prêt à être probablement
régurgiter parce que ça m'étonnerait que
ça ça allait partir dans les intestins
à moins que le relis beau don de soi
mort d'une énorme occlusion intestinale
extrêmement douloureuse à base de
registre 2b l'élite mais bref et surtout
l'intérêt de l'article le deuxième gros
intérieurs d'artix et d'introduire le
maupas bulitt donc les pabu lite qui
sont les c'est un nouveau mot 1 qui
viennent d'inventer et qui dit qui
désigne en fait les les fossiles de
trucs en train de se faire manger mais
qui n'ont pas encore été mangés parce
que d'habitude pour pour identifier les
choses qui ont été mangés ben on voit
les traces de dents et on voit la cee'd
stomacale qui a commencé à dissoudre les
carapaces où les eaux et ça permet
d'identifier un fossile comme comme
ayant fait partie d'un repas mais si
vous n'avez ni ses traces de dents nice
et nice est acide stomacale qui a
commencé à digérer comment vous savez
que le
que le fossile en question d'abord était
la proie de quelque chose d'autre
comment peut-on le savoir ben on peut
pas et c'est pour ça que ce genre de
fausses il n'avait pas de nom et donc
maintenant ils vont donc eu ce qu'ils
proposent c'est d'appeler ça dépanne
bulitt mais évidemment ce genre de pabu
lite donc comme le crustacé que vous
voyez là qui est en train de se faire à
manger mais qui n'a pas encore été
mangés
c'est un pas bu lite mais se met du coup
pour une condition des conditions de
préservation exceptionnelles quoi des
conditions la gare staaten de
préservation pour pouvoir avoir accès au
fait que ce soit des spas bulitt parce
que autrement si vous trouvez un bout de
crustacés juste comme ça vous saurai
jamais si ce bout de crustacés avait
d'abord été boulotter par un autre
animal s'il ya aucune trace de dents et
aucune trace de d'acide stomacale
d'acidité stomacale sur la carapace
ça va être compliqué c'est un peu le
problème d'ailleurs avec cette bd mi
temps c'est un peu le problème avec
cette belle et need c'est que là elle
est coupée en deux ok mais alors est ce
que ça veut dire que c'est un niveau
dont deux qu'il l'a coupé en deux
à moins de trouver des dents fichier des
dandys beaudottes fichiers à l'intérieur
vous le saurez pas donc est ce que cette
emule est ce que cette belle emnid
rentre dans la catégorie pop bulitt je
pense qu'on pourrait en débattre
voilà c'était paléo news je vous
remercie d'avoir suivi n'oubliez pas de
vous abonner pour ne rien manquer
d'anciens et je vous dis à très bientôt
[Musique]